quand je dis aux gens que j'ai fait des
études de géologie la première chose qui
me demandent ces caisses qui tourne pas
rond chez toi et la deuxième c'est est
ce que les géologues lâche vraiment des
cailloux alors non seulement oui mais je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi
en général quand un géologue tombe sur
un caillou dans la nature la première
chose qu'il a envie de faire c'est lui
donner un nom il peut l'appeler
jean-michel il peut l'appeler kevin mais
aussi il peut l'appeler argile ou alors
calcite où j'en ai pas d'autres et donc
pour l'identifier et ben le lécher ça
peut l'aider le souvient mes premiers
cours de géologie quand les profs nous
demandait de lécher des cailloux on
pensait que c'était une blague que c'est
un bizutage fin on comprenait pas très
bien mais n'ont apparemment ça fait
partie intégrante du procès ce même si
on n'avait pas forcément envie d'arriver
à ce degré d'intimité avec la planète
terre la première bonne raison de lécher
un caillou c'est parce que en fait on
quand on le mouiller on révèle certaines
structures ou alors on voit mieux les
minéraux parfois on ne voit même des
fossiles qu'on verrait pas d'habitude
donc ça c'est cool on peut aussi le
passé sous l'eau mais c'est moins fun et
puis ça gaspé une ressource naturelle et
on sait à quel point les géologues
tiennent compte de l'environnement
la deuxième bonne raison c'est parce que
lécher un caillou ça peut aider à
l'identifier parce qu'il peut avoir du
goût alors l'exemple le plus beau qu'on
prend à chaque fois c'est la lite la
ligue c'est ce qu'on appelle aussi le
sel gemme où le ciel de terre petite
parenthèse donc là à leeds as forme
en général quand il ya une mère ou un
océan qui s'évapore complètement et du
coup il laisse des dépôts de sel qui
vont fossilisés être enfouis mâchant
tout ça et donc du coup c'est assez
drôle parce qu'on trouve des gisements
de halit un peu partout en france
et en plus quand il ya des sources qui
ressurgissent à travers ces couches là
eh ben ça peut donner des sources d'eau
salée donc cessé à ses fans un des
éléments clés pour reconnaître la lite
basse et son goût salé petite
démonstration donc là ça n'a pas du tout
un goût salé parce que c'est de la
calcite en fait j'ai pas du tout de la
ligue chez moi
c'est drôle parce que la calcite et la
halle ide se ressemblent beaucoup incite
le gypse et c'est justement quand vous
lécher si vous avez un goût salé vous
arrivez à discriminer les uns des autres
j'ai toujours pas de élite mais par
contre j'ai été ramassés du sel au bord
d'un marais salants donc c'est pareil
c'est une roche qui se forme par
évaporation ce qu'on appelle une
évaporée et là pour le coup c'est sale
et sa race ça ira très bien sûr des
frites
voilà par contre c'est pas parce que
c'est sale et que c'est forcément de la
al ittihad autres minéraux qui ont aussi
un goût salé par exemple la cl vite
il paraît qu'en plus elle a un arrière
goût un peu amer jean vraiment dégueu
mais bon c'est quand même vachement
pratique parce que si votre offre un
goût salé
ça permet de limiter le champ de
recherche de plusieurs milliers de
minéraux je crois qu'on en a à 5000
connue à ce jour à deux douzaines donc
c'est plutôt pas mal
il ya d'autres minéraux coin goût amer
par exemple comme les psaumes itc a la
même composition chimique que le sulfate
de magnésium qu'on peut trouver en
magasin spécialisé
après on a la pyrite par exemple qui est
du sulfure de fer et qui du coup a un
goût et une odeur d'oeuf pourri donc
c'est toujours charmant après si votre
échantillon un petit goût de paradis
c'est elle aussi qui est un animal
sauvage qui s'est oublié dessus et ça
c'est pas plus mal parce qu'au final ça
renforce votre système immunitaire c'est
un peu le l'actimel du géologue et si
jamais votre échantillon a un goût de
chocolat bas c'est que c'est pas du tout
un caillou
[Musique]
la troisième bonne raison de lécher un
caillou c'est que ça permet d'estimer
grossièrement la porosité d'une roche
sissako la langue basque sait que c'est
pour eux ça c'est pratique pour
différencier les fossiles du reste du
monde parce que les fossiles en général
sont très poreux ceux qui ont un
squelette notamment ses avait composé de
d'élever hall qui sont remplis de vide
donc du coup bah ça boit l'eau et ça
c'est vachement pratique quand vous êtes
sur le terrain pour discriminer des
fossiles d'autres choses parce que vous
prenez un caillou qui a l'air de rien
vous le coller sur votre langue et si ça
ap votre langue c'est que c'est un
fossile voilà il ya aussi certains
minéraux qui vont coller à la langue
comme certains types d'argile alors on à
la cao limite à partir de laquelle est
faite la porcelaine et on a aussi la
mort you need que je vais vous raconter
un peu plus tard donc ces argiles elles
absorbent l'eau c'est comme ça c'est des
très bonnes réponses ça vient de leur
structure qui en feuillets entre
lesquels peuvent circuler des molécules
dont l'eau et donc du coup pas ça va
rester coller à votre langue un peu
comme une hostie
je vous parlais de la mort unit qui est
aussi la terre de sommières ça c'est un
des constituants de ce qu'on appelle les
argiles gonflante les argiles gonflante
c'est ce qui vous donne un peu ses
paysages à la roi lion l'été et en fait
ça c'est un peu la bête noire des gens
qui construisent des maisons parce que
comme une bonne éponges elles vont
gonfler quand il ya de l'eau et puis
elles vont complètement se rétracter le
reste du temps et du coup si vous avez
une maison de suba elle va se fissurer
ça à devenir une maison picasso pour la
petite histoire pause boisson
pour la petite histoire on a même trouvé
de la mort you need sur mars donc si
jamais vous y allez vous pouvez très
bien léché le sol et si ça reste collé à
votre langue est bien c'est que c'est de
l'amour unit ou alors c'est que vous
avez enlevé votre combinaison et du coup
votre tête a explosé elle est allé
rouler par terre elle est restée collée
au sol donc voilà les trois grandes
raisons qui expliquent pourquoi les
géologues aime bien léché des cailloux
en plus du grand plaisir de passer pour
un con ça peut aider à mieux voir de
quoi est composé un caillou à voir s'il
un goût particulier ou aussi a estimé
grossièrement sa porosité voir s'y colle
à la langue ou pas si vous aussi vous
voulez pratiquer ça à la maison
faites attention parce que c'est plus
dangereux que ça en a l'air ça dépend
des spécimens comprends mais y en a qui
peuvent être toxiques
il y en a qui contiennent de
l'arsenic du cadmium du mercure enfin de
plein de choses merveilleuses du plomb
aussi notamment comme cette galère tous
les cailloux ne sont pas inoffensifs
prenez de l'amiante par exemple c'est un
minéral donc faites attention si jamais
vous tester ça chez vous je ne vous
conseillerais qu'une chose c'est de le
faire bien entouré avec un géologue ou
un minéralogiste qui puisse vous dire ça
vous pouvez ça vous pouvez pas et tant
qu'à faire si vous voulez vous adonner
aux joies de lécher des cailloux autant
de faire dans les règles de l'art donc
il ya deux techniques
la première c'est de lécher votre doigt
de le passer sur l'échantillon et de
lécher à nouveau et ça normalement que
vous avez assez de goût pour pour sentir
le goût et vous ingérez pas pour autant
trop de particules au cas où l'autre
technique c'est de laisser poser le bout
de votre langue pendant quelques
secondes sur le caillou donc là ça n'a
aucun goût parce que c'est un quartz en
fait et donc pour finir désolé de briser
vos fantasmes mais les géologues ne
passent pas leur temps à lécher des
cailloux au fait ça fait partie du
processus d'identification parfois mais
en général c'est au dernier niveau donc
on a déjà éliminé toutes les autres
solutions
mais bon ça fait partie du folklore et
puis ça n'enlève rien à la magie de
l'instant
[Musique]
il
vous
tous
[Musique]
il
non
[Musique]
il
oh
on
vous
[Musique]
il
où
[Musique]
il
non
[Musique]
où
rond
m
amis
et
on
[Musique]